for the 27th year in a row walker's home  for the holidays happening for those in  need in clark county  some deserving families receiving a  whole house full of furniture for the  holidays including sylvia archuleta  received the first delivery this morning  one of her neighbors wrote a letter  after finding out she was raising  grandchildren  including two infant great grandsons  sylvia also experienced a great loss  after her husband was killed well i  really appreciate it  because i never had nothing new this is  the first time  it's really i mean it's the best  christmas ever to have you know  but uh i wish my husband would have been  here he passed away you know and  we were together for 43 years and he  just passed away  i wish he could see this  [Music]  34 other families will get an entire  household  of new furniture denise